ROBERT PUFKY: I'm Robert.
And today I have with
me Zach and James.
And today we're going to talk
about cloud support and how we
moved our internal support
stack into the cloud.
Now I actually want to talk to
you guys first and say, how
many of you guys have run
traditional IT stacks in the
past or are running
them currently?
Just a show of hands.
Wow, OK, a lot of people.
So our experience in moving our
stack to the cloud should
be pretty relative to you.
And for you guys that are
already running on App Engine
or are already running on cloud,
maybe you'll get some
good tips and tricks about
developing on App Engine.
So before we talk about this,
I want to talk a little bit
about the background of support
at Google and kind of
talk about how we do things.
So we can talk about the problem
analysis of where we
were before, the applications
that we developed, and where
we ended up.
So the first thing I'm going
to talk about is Techstops.
And Techstops are really a
central point at Google in a
lot of the offices where anyone
can go at any time for
help with any kind of problem.
It could be a technical issue.
It could be software.
It could be hardware issues.
It could really be anything.
And what you expect to find here
is you come in, and you
have fun and friendly techs that
can answer your questions
quickly and get you on your
way and make you be more
productive.
These techs are actually
called field techs.
And in smaller offices, they
equate to something like an IT
site director or something like
that because they also do
a lot of the site work
at smaller offices.
We also have a program called
the ITR program, or the
Internal Technology Residency
program, which is a two year
program where we pull students
from colleges that have just
recently graduated.
We put them through a two-year
process where we show them how
Google does IT.
And we put them on
an ops rotation.
An ops rotation is like a
three-month rotation with an
operations team where they
can go and learn what
operations teams do.
My team is the Support
Engineering Development team.
And both Zach and James did
ops rotations with me.
Additionally, they do office
rotations, where they go and
work for three months in another
office and get an idea
of what all our offices
are like.
Now to get back to the support
at Google, really, our core
goal in Google in support is
to make sure that users'
problem are fixed the first
time, they're fixed quickly,
and they're happy
and productive.
And this is really key.
It leads to a lot of really
high customer
satisfaction scores.
But that's not really what
we're focusing on.
We're focusing on users being
really productive. .
And that's where we get into
this conversation we're going
to talk about today.
And it's our frustration with
the traditional IT stacks that
we were running before.
And these are great, actually.
A lot of IT professionals
come in.
They've written applications
on these stacks before.
They write quick applications
here and there, even build up
some large-scale applications.
And that's great.
But we've found some
problems with it.
We actually experienced a lot
of application development,
and then we had to scale
it to meet our demands.
We have offices all over the
world, on every continent
except for Antarctica.
So when we launched an
application, we literally had
to make sure that everyone in
the world could use it when we
launched it.
And with traditional IT stacks,
we really got to focus
on not only the application
development but how we can
scale that to the world.
And this was a really
big problem.
Because our team is generally
small, we didn't have DBAs and
sysops and SREs.
SREs are Site Reliability
Engineers, essentially keep
stuff up and running.
And we came to an injunction
where we wanted to say, should
we actually go and hire these
people to help scale this
infrastructure for us?
Or should we actually take a
look at the core problems in
the group and see if we can come
up with a different way,
a better way to solve
these issues?
So what we did is we went in,
and we did a problem analysis
on our group.
And we tried to figure out
what was wrong in our
development group as well as
what was wrong in the support
organization and how
we could fix this.
So we pondered on these
issues a little bit.
And we found the first thing,
and probably the biggest
thing, is that we found that
maintenance versus innovation
was a huge issue.
We were spending a lot of
our time scaling our
infrastructure, keeping
it up and running.
Spending a lot of time just
making sure it was running as
opposed to innovating in our
space and really fixing the
core issues that our team
was there to solve.
We also found that a lack
of tech information, or
information presented to techs
in the Techstops, led to a lot
more escalations in
pages and bugs.
And what that really meant is
that the end user was not
getting their problem fixed
as fast as possible.
So we wanted to make sure that
our techs were getting the
information that they needed so
they could be empowered to
make the right decisions
and get people
on their way faster.
We also looked at the approvals
and how we did approvals.
We found that if a tech is
fixing a user's computer, and
their hardware is busted, why
should they wait for a manager
two levels away to approve
a hardware swap?
Why can't the tech just make
the determination that the
hardware's busted
and swap it out?
What if the tech is working at
a Techstop, and the location
has changed, or the phone
number has changed?
Why should they go through an
approval mechanism to get
those changes made?
Why can't they just go and
make these changes
immediately?
We also looked at the automation
for our group.
And what we really wanted to get
done here is to remove a
lot of the mundane task work
from the Techstops so they can
focus on interesting problems.
We did a little bit of this with
traditional IT stacks.
But we really wanted to do this
automation work and then
not have to think about
it and keep it up and
running later on.
We also looked in the
self-service.
Now if a Googler takes an
average of 5 to 10 minutes to
walk to a Techstops, that means
that there's 10 to 20
minutes of that Googler's day
just lost just walking to the
Techstop without actually even
getting their problem fixed.
So what we wanted to take a look
at is if we could provide
information to our end users
so they can fix their own
problems, maybe in two or three
minutes, as opposed to
spending all that time walking
to and from the Techstop.
And again, this is something
that we need to do at a global
scale so that when we launch
an application or a
self-service application,
everyone can use it.
The last thing was slow
applications.
And again, we've, touched on
this before, so I'm not going
to hammer away at this.
But this is really scaling
applications and making sure
they're fast and responsive to
people that are using them.
The last thing we looked at, and
I'll give you a minute to
look at this graph, is our
application history and what
it was like from inception
'til death.
And what you'll see here
is a histogram.
And this is basically a
histogram of the applications
that we developed over time.
And what we did was we put a
trend line over this data.
And we found that there's
actually a really nice normal
or bell curve about the average
lifespan of our
applications that we
were developing.
And this was a key insight to
our problem because we were
fundamentally different
designing our
applications wrong.
We were originally aiming to
build them to be 10- to
15-year applications, to
be self-healing, to be
self-replicating, to fail over
to other DCs, et cetera, et
cetera, DCs being
Data Centers.
And it really turned out that
our application lifespan was
only two to four years.
So we only really wanted
to focus on getting an
application out, making sure
it scaled to the world.
It did what it needed to do.
We could add features when we
needed to, and we could turn
it down without actually needing
to work on all the
maintenance stuff.
We looked into why applications
were lasting only
two to four years, and we came
up with a couple interesting
points as well.
First was technology changes.
Some of our systems interacted
with tech stacks, and these
tech stacks got deprecated.
So therefore there was no
point in having those
applications.
Second, we looked at internal
process changes.
We're constantly evolving,
and our internal
processes change a lot.
So some applications were
deprecated by processes.
And the third and probably the
most important was security
and scaling issues that
we were having these
applications.
Again, our team was just a
small team of developers.
And we were having a lot
of issues scaling our
applications because we needed
to get dedicated
resources to do it.
We also looked in the security
aspect and really found out
that in traditional stacks,
you have to worry about OS
security, how many users have
access to the system, the
security of your serving
sack as well as the
security of your code.
And then what happens when a
data center fails, and you
need to fail over to another
data center?
We really wanted to remove all
of that from the equation and
really focus on writing the
application itself.
So with these problems
identified, we set forth to
migrate a lot of our
applications
to something better.
And I'm going to introduce Zach,
who's going to talk a
little bit about Techstop
information, which is one of
these applications that we
developed using these problems
that we identified
and helped solve.
Zach?
ZACH SZAFRAN: My name's
Zach Szafran.
I'm an IT resident, and I work
in those Techstops that Bob
was just telling you about.
So recently, I had the chance
to work with Bob and some of
his support engineers on their
cloud-based applications.
Techstop Info is one of those
projects I got to work on.
In the next couple slides, I'm
going to talk about it and how
we implemented some
of its features.
So originally, we had this
version-controlled YAML file.
This was the authoritative
source for all of our Techstop
information.
Any application that needed
this type of Techstop info
would actually have to sync
down their own copy
of this YAML file.
So if you take a minute and just
look over this example
that we have here, you might
see some human errors that
we've included.
These are actual human
errors that you could
find in our YAML file.
So maybe by show of hands, does
anyone see any obvious
problems with this?
It's kind of hard to tell.
So the first, less obvious
problem is the fact our
indentation is incorrect.
If we ran strict parsing across
this YAML file, it
would fail.
The more obvious issue
is the fact our
phone number was incorrect.
And things like this did make
it into our YAML file.
So let's say a technician found
this phone number in our
YAML file, and he wanted
to actually fix it.
What kind of process would
they have to go
through to get this done?
So in order to make this change,
they'd have to go to
our repo, find the file,
and sync it down
to the local machine.
Once they have the file, they
would make their change, fix
the phone number, whatever
they need to do.
And then they would save it.
At which point, they would
submit it for review, where it
would be checked for spelling
errors, syntax,
style guide, et cetera.
And then the reviewer would
give the approval and say,
looks good to me.
After this, it's up to the
technician to submit this file
back up to the repository, where
any application that
depends on the YAML format would
have to sync it down.
At which point, they could
use it or display it
however they want.
So in order to crowdsource this
a little easier and avoid
that tedious process for making
small changes, we set
up this App Engine-based
replacement.
We provided a UI for making
all these changes.
And in addition to that, we
include audit logs for all the
changes that are made.
So now I'm going to demo
Techstop Info a little bit,
just so you have an idea of what
it's about and what some
of its features are.
So here, a technician could
come to our website.
And they're immediately
presented a list of Techstops.
So let's say the technician
coming here actually wanted to
fix a phone number.
And they know the Techstops
managed by Bob.
Using a Gmail-like search query,
we can kind of filter
this down a little bit.
But that wasn't really
specific enough.
So let's say we also know the
Techstop that Bob manages is
on floor two.
And since that's the only result
of our query, we're
taken directly into the
Techstop, where phone numbers
could be changed or updated.
Also, an important note would
be the audit log that
we have down here.
This basically says James was
the last person to edit this
Techstop info.
And if we wanted to dig down a
little deeper into this, we
could get a full audit trail
and actually see all the
changes that were made to this
Techstop, who made them, and
what the changes were.
So now that I've shown you
Techstop Info and the
Gmail-like search querying, I'm
going to explain a little
bit about how we implemented
that.
Really, all we ended up doing
is filtering based off the
models, our datastore's
model attributes.
So to do this, we set up this
GetTechstopList method.
And really, all it does is it
takes a query from the UI and
decides what to do with it.
So the first check we do is
for a colon in the query.
And that says it is a
Gmail-like query.
So we pass it along to the
GetListByAttributeQuery
method, which I'll talk about
in the next slide.
And then if it isn't a
Gmail-like query, we just take
what was entered in the UI, and
we use it as a standard
term for a Datastore search.
So the GetListByAttributeQuery
method is what actually parses
a Gmail-like query.
Really, all it does is take this
query, split it up into
attribute names and values,
and then we start looping
through them all.
So we check our Techstop
model to ensure
that it has this attribute.
And if it doesn't, we
inform the user that
their query was invalid.
But if it does have it, what
we'll do is we'll take our
current list of Techstops, and
we'll start pruning out the
ones that don't have that
attribute or value.
What we're left with at the
end of this is a list of
Techstops that match the entire
query, meaning every
attribute and value, and
then we return them.
So the
IntersectResultsWithAttribute
method does pretty much
what it says.
It takes our current list of
tech stops, and it prunes the
ones that don't have this
attribute or value.
So originally, when we run this
method, we don't have a
current results that
no Techstops.
So what we do is just a standard
Datastore search with
a little bit of filtering
involved.
Once we get those current
results up, it actually will
start passing it in to here.
And we'll start looping through
each of the Techstops
in that result set.
What we're doing is checking
to make sure that they have
that attribute or value.
And if they don't, we just
don't include it
in our return results.
These three functions here are
really what allow us to
implement the search querying.
And it allows our application
to quickly provide relevant
information to the techs that
are visiting our website.
I mentioned a little earlier in
the demo that we have these
audit logs for keeping track of
all the changes that happen
to this Techstop info.
We use the SaveTechstop method
here for actually writing the
Techstops to the Datastore.
So inside, we have this private
transaction method.
And you can see that it's
actually putting the Techstop
in the Datastore.
In return, we get a Techstop
key, which we can then use to
build this audit entry with.
The audit entry says who made
the change, what attributes
were changed, and what
their new values are.
And then we write to
the Datastore too.
We take that private transaction
method, and we run
it in the db.run_in_transaction.
And that ensures that both the
Techstop entity and our audit
entity get written
to the Datastore.
I also mentioned that we have
a corporate database.
What we're doing is we're taking
our Datastore with all
of its Techstop information,
and we're syncing it out to
this corporate database.
Really, the database is meant
for storing all this
org-related information, so
applications that depend on
that can easily access it.
With all of our Techstop info
in here, all the website has
to do is authenticate to the
corporate database, and all
this information's made
available to them.
We don't have to administrate
an API access or give direct
App Engine access to
our application.
A really good example of the
types of services that consume
our Techstop info from the
corporate database would be an
internal overlay we have
for Google Maps.
This displays all of our
corporate locations.
And that just happens to include
all of our Techstops.
So at this point, a technician
can come to our new
application we have set up, make
some changes to Techstop,
like the name, phone number,
or GPS coordinates.
And then upon saving that, it's
automatically updated in
this Maps overlay.
And another pretty good example
is the fact that all
of our end user documentation,
as well as call centers, have
access to our new application.
So they really don't have to
worry about a phone number
being wrong or a room
number being old.
As long as it's updated in our
application, it's made
immediately accessible
to them.
So if you take a minute
and just look
over this graph here.
What we're showing are all the
edits to all Techstop data
that have ever happened.
In the blue, we have all the
edits to our YAML file.
And in the red, we have all the
audit logs currently in
our data store.
I'm going to switch this to a
log scale, just to make it a
little easier to see.
So again in the blue,
our YAML edits.
And what this is displaying is
about 107 edits over the
period of three years.
In the red, again, are
the audit logs.
And what those are displaying
are about 1,072 audit logs in
the period of five months.
That's about a 72-fold increase
in overall edits to
our Techstop data.
And this should paint a pretty
clear picture about what can
happen when you give complete
control over the data to the
people that use it and depend
on it the most.
There's a couple spikes
in this graph that I'd
like to point out.
This very last blue spike was
actually caused by us.
Those human errors I talked
about earlier needed corrected
in order to import all this data
into our new application.
So we had to go through and
manually correct all this, and
that's what caused that
very last spike there.
But after doing that and
importing all this into our
application, we were
able to release it.
At which point, all of our
technicians kind of flooded to
the site to check it out.
And they actually corrected any
old, invalid, or missing
data for our Techstops.
And that's what caused
this spike here.
And then this last spike was
actually caused by us again.
But unlike the YAML spike that
I talked about, we didn't
actually have to manually
make all these edits.
We were able to send out
an email to all of our
technicians saying, we're
making a global change,
informing them of this.
And they were actually able to
make this change for us.
We essentially were able
to crowdsource a global
modification without us having
to do very much.
So now that I've talked about
Techstop Info and some of its
features, I'm going to pass this
off to James, who's going
to talk about another support
application called Unified
Travel Manager.
JAMES MEADOR: Thanks, Zach.
Hi, everyone.
My name is James Meador.
And I'm also an IT resident
at Google in the Internal
Technology Residency program.
For my operations rotation in
this program, I was fortunate
enough to get to spend some time
with Bob and the Support
Engineering team
that he leads.
The majority of my time spent
on rotation was spent
designing and developing this
application called Unified
Travel Manager.
Now the design requirements for
this application called
for an application that had a
modular framework and not only
eased future development, but
encouraged it as well.
Before we get into some of the
technical details about
Unified Travel Manager, or UTM,
as we frequently call it,
I want to give you a little
background information about
how we handle travel
at Google.
Now in a typical IT support
organization, if a technician
decides to take vacation or gets
sick or takes leave, the
responsibilities will be
offloaded to another member of
their team or another
team entirely.
This can be a particularly large
problem for a smaller
office that's run by one
or two technicians.
At Google, we try to mitigate
the effects of this by using
what we call travel requests.
Now, a travel request is
something that a technician
can open if they have
a planned absence.
And then another technician can
fill that travel request.
The same concept kind of
applies for events.
So like Google I/O,
we have a need for
technical support here.
And what we can do is we can
open a travel request, and
then multiple technicians can
fill that travel request.
This can pose some
concerns, though.
What if more than one Googler
or technician wants to fill
one of these travel requests?
What if a manager thinks that
a different technician is
better suited to handle a
higher-profile event, like
Google I/O?
This is where we got the idea
for the first iteration of
Unified Travel Manager.
The first version was focused on
the application process to
a travel request.
So if Bob knew he was headed to
the Bahamas for a week, he
could open a travel application
that both Zach and
myself could apply to.
Bob or his manager would then be
able to select which one of
us was going to be lucky enough
to cover his position.
Now the first version
of UTM was great.
But after the problem analysis
that Bob talked about, we
wanted to move this
application to a
no-maintenance cloud solution.
And we really feel that Google
App Engine was the best fit
for this application.
The three things in UTM that we
want to talk to you about
are the modular framework and
design, a distinction between
application administrators and
application developers, and
some of the caching strategies
that we used, along with an
implementation of what we call
NDB, or Next Database, which
is a new Datastore API.
Before we do that, however, I
want to give you a quick demo
of UTM so you can kind of see
what it looks like it and how
the modules work.
Now what you can see here is
the admin panel for UTM.
On the left, we've got
a manager module
and a travel module.
In the middle, we've got
read access groups and
write access groups.
And you can see that technicians
and support
engineering are two groups that
have read access to the
travel module.
On the right, we've got two
on/off switches here.
And these allow us to enable
or disable these
modules on the fly.
I'm going to go ahead and open
the travel travel module here.
So what you can see
here is a list of
the open travel requests.
Now I'm going to go ahead
and create a new one.
Now I'll go ahead and set the
destination here to the
Moscone Center and set the start
date and end date to the
duration of Google I/O. I'll
set the priority too high
because this is kind
of important.
I'll also change the needed
bodies to three because we
need three technicians.
And I'll specify that this is
for Google I/O. I'll go ahead
and save this travel
request and head
back out to the overview.
Now if we refresh the page, you
can kind of see that it's
not showing up right now.
But what we can do is we head
back into the admin panel and
flip this module on and off.
Go ahead and turn the module
off, refresh the page.
It disappears from
the nav bar.
I'll go ahead and turn
the module back on.
The other thing we were going
to show you in this
application is the manager
module that you saw in the
module list.
Now at Google, we handle travel
differently, like we
talked about.
And part of this is we have what
we call travel managers.
Now a travel manager is somebody
that's responsible
for the travel coming in
and going out of a
certain site or region.
And these travel managers have
access to what we call the
manager module in
our application.
The manager module allows
these travel managers to
specify who they manage
the travel for.
So in the UI, they can type in
the name of a user and then
drag that user to one of the
different groups on the site.
They can also specify a group
or team, like technicians or
support engineering that
we showed you.
And then that'll send off an
Ajax request to the back end,
which will then return
a list of all the
users in that group.
So now that we've shown you
about half of our demo of the
application, we want to go
through some of the modular
design of UTM.
Now this is our class structure
for the modular
overview of the application.
On the left, we've got
webappRequestHandler.
And in the middle, we've got
ParentRequestHandler.
And on the right, you can see
ModuleRequestHandler.
Now each of these are subclasses
of each other.
So Parent Request Handler
is a subclass of the
webapp Request Handler.
And the Module Request Handler
is then, again, a subclass of
that Parent Request Handler.
We think of our relationship
between the Parent Request
Handler and the Module Request
Handler a lot like the
relationship between
a motherboard and
an expansion card.
The motherboard, or our Parent
Request Handler, is
responsible for most of the
basic routing and other
remedial tasks and utilities
that are associated with
running the application.
The Module Request Handler, or
the expansion card, is focused
on adding features and
functionality, the bells and
whistles kinds of things.
Now on top of the class
structure, what you see is the
path that an HTTP request will
take through the application.
We'll go into more detail about
this in a little bit.
But the general gist is that an
HTTP request flows all the
way from the webapp Request
Handler down to the Module
Request Handler, and then back
out to the user through the
webapp Request Handler.
Now to do that, however, we have
to know which modules are
responsible for processing
which requests.
Now this mapping of URLs to
methods happens in the
constructors for the Parent
Request Handler and the Module
Request Handler.
Let's take a look at what
these look like.
Now I really like tacos.
So we're going to take and
build an application here
called IOLunchHandler.
This is going to take care of
the ordering of lunch for
Google I/O.
Now this is our Parent
Request Handler.
And it's inheriting from
webapp.RequestHandler.
This is the constructor
for IO Lunch Handler.
Now we'll go ahead and call the
constructor for the super.
And we'll initialize two
dictionaries, method and
template mappings.
We'll then call InitSubHandler.
We don't want all of our
modules to override the
constructor of the Parent
Request Handler because in our
live application, we've got some
additional functionality
and processing that
happens here.
So this is a module called
TacoHandler.
It's inheriting from
IO Lunch Handler.
And what we'll do is we'll
define this Init Sub Handler
method that we just called.
In this case, we'll call a
method MapURLToMethod.
Now what this does is it tells
the Parent Request Handler
that we're going to process all
requests to /tacos with
the DisplayTacos method.
Now remember the Display Tacos
name because we're going to
talk about that in
a little bit.
Let's look at what the Map URL
To Method function looks like.
This method lives on the
Parent Request Handler.
And here's the definition
of it.
We'll use the URL as the key in
these two dictionaries that
we created in the constructor.
And we'll assign a definition
of the method in the method
mappings dictionary.
And the template's file name
is a string in the template
mappings dictionary.
If we have a lot of modules in
our application, they can be a
little difficult
to keep track.
So we put together a class
called ModuleManager that's
going to help with this.
Module Manager functions a lot
like a dictionary in Python,
but with some additional
functionality.
We'll use this handler's
dictionary here to keep track.
One of the utility methods
on the Module Manager is
something called AddHandler.
Now what this is going to do
is it's going to take the
definition of a handler.
And it's going to use the
handler's name as the key in
that handler's dictionary.
We'll also create an instance of
the handler here and store
that as the value in
the dictionary.
The reason we're creating an
instance is because we want to
make sure that the Init Sub
Handler method is called so
that all of the URL to method
mapping can take place.
Another utility method on the
Module Manager is called
GetURLMappings.
Now what this does is it
iterates through the
dictionary's keys.
And it creates a list
of [? tuples ?]
based on the URL in the handler
that's responsible for
processing requests destined
for that URL.
Now that we have this class
defined, this is how we go
about using it.
We'll go ahead and create
an instance of the
Module Manager class.
And then we'll add the Taco
Handler to the class.
Now that we've got some data in
that dictionary, we can use
the Get URL Mappings method here
and pass the results of
that to webapp.WSGIApplication.
This is what tells App Engine
what URLs are responsible for
processing which request
and what handlers those
will get routed to.
The next thing we want to do
is talk about how an HTTP
request goes through
our application.
Now that we know which handlers
and which modules are
responsible for processing
which
requests, we can do this.
Now whenever App Engine sees an
HTTP Get request come into
your application, it's going to
fire off the Get method on
the subclass of webapp
Request Handler.
In our case, that's going to
be the Get method on the
Parent Request Handler.
So let's take a look at
what that looks like.
This is the I/O Lunch
Handler again, our
Parent Request Handler.
And the definition of the Get
method is right here.
Now we'll use those
dictionaries
that we just populated.
And we'll get the path
for the HTTP request
from the request object.
We'll then look up the Get
method that's responsible for
processing this HTTP request
and store that here.
We'll do the same for the
template's file name.
Now we'll call that
Get method.
We'll store the results
of this Get method in
template_params.
So we're going to jump out of
the Parent Request Handler and
into the Module Request
Handler while we
run this Get method.
So we just left the Parent
Request Handler's call module
method portion, and we're headed
into the module method
portion of the Module
Request Handler.
So here's the Taco Handler
module we showed you a little
earlier and the Display Tacos
method that I mentioned.
Now we'll create a dictionary
here with some pretty basic
taco types in it, chicken and
beef, for this example.
And we'll return that dictionary
back to the Parent
Request Handler for
processing.
We're then stepping out of the
module and back into the
Parent Request Handler for
some template rendering.
Let's take a look at what
this looks like.
This is still happening
in that Get method.
So what we'll do is we'll call
App Engine's template.render.
We'll pass in the file name and
the dictionary with the
parameters to render
to that template.
And then we'll render that
response to the output stream.
Now this design lets us do
some interesting things.
The first that we're going to
talk about is the ability to
administratively disable
modules.
Now we showed you briefly in
the demo how we had those
on/off switches that allow
us to toggle on
or off these modules.
A lot of this processing and
validation happens in the
constructor for the Parent
Request Handler.
So here's the Taco Handler
module again.
And we're going to assign a
module ID of "tacos." we use
this ID whenever we store some
basic data about our modules
in Datastore.
Next, what you see is a method
called ValidateSubHandler.
Now this method is on the
Parent Request Handler.
And it's responsible for making
sure that all of the
modules are implementing the
module design correctly.
The first thing we'll do is
we'll make sure that the
module has defined an ID.
If it hasn't, then we'll raise
an attribute error.
If we do have a module ID, then
we'll fetch our module
entity from Datastore based
on that module ID.
If Datastore doesn't return
anything, or it does return a
module, but the module's
disabled, then we'll raise a
NotConfiguredError.
This is just a custom error in
our application that lets us
know whenever a module's
accessed when it
shouldn't have been.
Another thing we can do with
this design is implement
granular access control
at the module level.
Now App Engine provides you
with 10 application
administrators and application
developers in the console that
you can configure.
But we wanted to
expand on that.
We were already implementing
our own user
authentication model.
So this was actually
kind of simple.
Let's show you what we did.
Now what you can see here is
a user in module model.
Now the user model has a list of
groups because the user can
be a member of multiple
groups.
For instance, Zach is a member
of both technicians and
support engineering.
And a module has an
ACL right here.
You can see read groups, write
groups, and admi groups.
Now if a technician needed
access to a specific module,
then the technicians group would
be on one of these ACLs,
let's say, for instance,
the admin group.
But how do we intersect the
user's groups with the
module's ACL?
Well, we use a decorator.
So in our decorators.py file,
we have a decorator called
RequiresModuleAdmin.
Now the method that we're
decorating that's passed in is
the handler_method argument
of this method.
The IsModuleAdmin
is the closure
method inside this decorator.
Now what it's going to do is
it's going to use App Engine's
users API to fetch the
currently logged
in user's user name.
We'll then take that user
name and fetch our
user entity from Datastore.
We'll also get a list
of the admin groups
for the current module.
If we have a user entity in
our Datastore for the
currently logged in user, then
we'll intersect that user's
groups with the admin groups
for the module.
If there is an intersection
there, then we'll go ahead and
call the handler method that
we're decorating with the
arguments that were passed in.
If there's no intersection, then
we'll simply error out
with a 403.
Now putting this functionality
in a decorator makes it really
simple to use an implement
throughout all of our modules.
What we can do is any method
that requires the currently
logged in user to have module
admin rights, we can just put
the decorator on top of
the method definition.
In this situation, it's just
a ChangeLunchItems method.
So now that we've talked about
the modular overview and
design of UTM and a distinction
between
application administrators and
developers, we want to talk a
little bit about our caching
strategies that we used in
this application.
Now who here likes
a slow website?
That's unfortunate.
So slow websites waste
people's time.
If you load a page, and it takes
more than five seconds
to load, you've probably
already moved on
to something else.
Now this was one of the main
reasons we moved our
application into the cloud.
We wanted to make sure that page
load times were quick.
We wanted to make sure that
users didn't have to wait
forever whenever they were
trying to access the data that
they needed.
And one of the things that we
did was we implemented a
memcache to store the results
of all of our
expensive method calls.
We also did this through
a decorator.
You'll see the definition of
a cache decorator here with
function passed in
as the argument.
Now CachedFunction is the method
here that's going to do
most of our heavy lifting.
We'll build a key based on the
function's name that we're
decorating and a list of the
ordered arguments and keyword
arguments that were passed
in to the method.
Once we have this key,
we'll try to fetch
a value from memcache.
If memcache has anything stored,
then we'll simply
return that back out
to the caller.
But if we don't have anything
in memcache, we'll need to
call the method that we're
decorating, store those
results in memcache,
and then return
that back to the caller.
Another thing that we did was
we implemented something
called Next Database.
I mentioned earlier that this
is a new API on top of App
Engine's Datastore.
Now one of the features that
NDB provides is something
called structured properties.
Structured properties allow
you to retain some of the
organizational benefits that a
normalized database gives you,
but in a non-relational
database like
App Engine's Datastore.
Let's take a look
at what we did.
So what you can see here is
a travel application model
that's based on ndb.Model
instead of DB.
We'll create a user property
here just for the
sake of this example.
We'll also define a travel
request model here.
Now we talked about how UTM is
focused on the application
process for these
travel requests.
This is actually an abbreviated
example of exactly
what we do in our application.
So we have an
approved_applications property
on the travel request itself.
We'll define this is as an
ndb.StructuredProperty that's
based on the travel
application.
We'll tell NDB that this is a
repeated argument by setting
this to true.
Now what this does is it allows
us to store data about
the application on the
request object.
This is how we'd go about
putting one of these requests
and applications in Datastore.
We'll create a travel
application with the user
property set to the currently
logged in user.
We'll then create an empty
travel request.
We'll set the approved
applications property on this
travel request to a list
of length one with the
application in that list.
We'll then put the travel
request into Datastore.
You'll note, however, that we
never actually store the
travel application itself.
It's an ndb.Model, but we never
called the .put method.
The reason for this is the
travel application is stored
on the travel request itself.
Whenever you put a travel
request into Datastore, it's
going to store the travel
application
information with it.
Whenever you fetch the travel
request from Datastore, NDB's
going to reconstruct that
travel application
model on the fly.
So if you were to have any
utility methods defined on the
NDB model, in this case, travel
application, all those
methods would just work.
There wouldn't be any problem
with getting those methods to
map correctly.
Now this is a method called
GetTravelRequests.
This is a method that's in our
application that fetches all
of the travel requests
from Datastore.
It performs some processing
on those requests.
And then it returns the results
of that processing
back to the caller.
This is one of the methods that
does a lot of processing
and Datastore operations, so we
wanted to use the caching
decorator on this method.
Every time we hit the method,
we don't want it to run.
So we'll check memcache
to see if we have
something stored for it.
If memcache has anything, we'll
just return that back to
the caller.
But if it doesn't, we'll have to
go through this processing
the next time we call
the function.
The other thing I want to show
you is a feature called hooks
that NDB provides.
These aren't available
in Datastore, in
the original DB API.
But NDB provides
these for you.
Now this is a travel
request model.
And we're going to define what
we call a pre_put_hook.
Now NDB's going to fire off this
method before you perform
any Datastore Puts on a travel
request in this situation.
For this example, we'll just
call memcache.flush_all, but
we could really do anything
we want here.
Zach showed you how we used
audit trails in Techstop Info.
We could actually use that
same logic here.
Now these hooks are available
for all of your Datastore
operations, your Puts, your
Gets, and your Deletes.
And you can specify the hook to
run before or after those
operations.
Now implementing all of these
caching strategies led to some
pretty astounding results.
Now what you can see here is
worst case cold cache load
times for a reporting page
in our application.
Now this reporting page fetched
a lot of travel
requests from Datastore.
So it did some processing on
this as well, which is why the
DB load time is at 21 seconds.
Now after implementing NDB
structured properties, we got
this down to about 1
and 1/2 seconds.
The reason for this is all of
the travel requests in NDB now
store all of the travel
applications on the travel
request object itself.
So with DB implementation, the
relationship between travel
requests and travel applications
was that of a
parent/child relationship.
So any time we'd fetch a travel
request from Datastore,
we'd have to go and fetch the
travel applications as well.
With the NDB implementation,
this was a lot quicker, thanks
to structured properties.
Now we will note that if you
were to switch directly from
DB to using NDB without
implementing things like
structured properties or any
other caching, you might
notice a slight performance
decrease simply because NDB
has a little bit more
overhead for the new
features that it adds.
Now that we've talked about some
of the caching strategies
for UTM, and we've talked about
the modular design of
the application, I'm going to
pass it back off to Bob for
some results and conclusions.
ROBERT PUFKY: Thanks, James.
You know, they say live demos
never work, and I think we
just proved that.
So I want to just wrap this up
and talk about the results we
got from moving our application
stack to the cloud
and the benefits that our team
got from it, as well as our
organization.
And the first thing that I want
to talk about is Platform
as a Service, and how it
actually really works for us.
It's really a paradigm shift in
application development for
us in the sense that we're
focused on actually developing
and solving fundamental issues
and innovating in our space,
as opposed to developing and
maintaining stuff at the same
time,
We're focusing on the people at
hand and the problems and
not focusing on keeping
stuff up and running.
It's also no longer part of your
core tasks to keep these
services running.
You don't have to worry about
stuff going down.
We also found out as we started
moving more and more
to the cloud that we had a lot
of really intrinsic benefits
to this as well.
There was a definite hump when
we got about partway through
our cloud migration that we
spent a lot less time late
nights and weekends at work.
And this was obviously
maintenance, putting out fires
like we were doing
in the past.
All that was gone.
So we actually had a
really large morale
increase on our team.
As well as it was just a better
work-life balance.
People would come in, and they'd
know they would work
Monday through Friday,
nine to five.
And they could go camping on
the weekend and not worry
about carrying a pager or worry
about something going
down, they needed a failover.
And this was pretty huge.
And really, at the end of the
day, guys, it was about our
end users and making sure that
they were up and running and
being productive as possible.
And the cloud platform, App
Engine, allowed us to do this
via Developers by allowing us
to focus on the problems at
hand, allowing us to instantly
scale to the world, as well as
allowing our techs and enabling
our techs to have the
information at hand to make
empowered decisions to get
people out of the Techstop
faster and being more
productive.
Additionally, our users,
Googlers, are happier as well
because they can actually
get their work done.
They don't need to wait for
problems to be solved or
information to be had.
So that's it with the
presentation.
We have about a minute 30 left,
I think, before we're
switching sessions.
So thank you guys very
much for attending.
I really appreciate it.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT PUFKY: If you have any
questions that we can't answer
during the Q and A, since it's
going to be so short, just
come and find me, and we
can talk about it.